cyber security professionals are gaining
paramount importance in today's era
given the current scenario the need for
cyber security professionals is
witnessing a huge spike
the field of cyber security is advancing
rapidly
hence to keep up with this space cyber
security professionals are required to
upskill and be updated with the latest
advancements
taking up certifications is the best way
to do this
certifications play a vital role in a
cyber security professional's career
one such important certification is the
comptia security plus certification
on that note hey guys welcome to yet
another informative video by simply
learn
in this video we will brief you about
the famous comptia security plus
certification
this video will provide all the details
you need in order to be comptia security
plus certified
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed already
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon for interesting tech
videos every day
so let's get started first let me
briefly introduce comptia before moving
on to the comptia security plus
certification
the computing technology industry
association or better known as comptia
is a leading vendor-neutral i.t
certification provider in the world
comtia is considered one of the top
trade associations
its vendor neutral certification program
is undoubtedly one of the best in the it
industry
for more than two decades comptia has
developed certification exams and
training for networking security
open source development and cloud to
name a few
comptia certifications continue to
address the requirements and necessities
of today's technology challenges
comptia certifications are grouped by
skill set
presently comptia certifications are
classified into four areas
core infrastructure cyber security and
additional professional certifications
if you have a job that may involve some
sort of certification
you must consider obtaining that
certification certifications are very
crucial
comptia certifications are a way for it
professionals to demonstrate their
knowledge of computers
let us now have a look at a few of the
certifications offered by comptia
first we have comptia a plus comptia a
plus certification is an entry level
certification for it technicians
this certification is designed for
employees who are seeking a career as a
support service center or networking
technician
this certification tests a candidate's
understanding of basic networking
troubleshooting and security skills
it covers laptop and pc hardware
software installation and configuration
of operating systems
according to comptia more than one
million it professionals hold the a plus
certification
next we have comptia network plus
you can either start with the a plus
certification however if you have the
experience you can move directly to the
comptia network plus certification
this certification is for professionals
who carry a minimum of nine months of
networking experience
here a candidate must be familiar with
networking technologies topology
security installation and configuration
and troubleshooting of wireless and
wired network devices
next we have comptia security plus
comptia security plus covers network
security concepts
threats and vulnerabilities access
control identity management
cryptography and much more we will
closely look at the comptia security
plus certification in this video
and finally this comptia cloud plus the
comptia cloud plus certification finds
its importance
as the cloud computing market continues
to grow by leaps and bounds
this certification targets it
professionals with two to three years of
experience in storage
networking or data center administration
the certification
exam tests the candidates knowledge of
cloud technologies
cloud markets and hybrid and multi-cloud
solutions
those were a few of the certifications
offered by comptia
there are several other certifications
like comtia linux plus
comptia pentest plus and comptia project
plus to name a few
now let us have a look at the comtia
security plus certification in detail
so what is the comptia security plus
certification
well the comptia security plus
certification is a leading entry-level
it certification
it is an essential certification for
professionals working in the it industry
it is one of the first security
certifications that must be earned by it
professionals
it provides the core knowledge required
of any cyber security role
and provides a spring boot to various
intermediate level cyber security jobs
this certification teaches you how to
secure applications devices and networks
it also focuses on hands-on practical
skills in the field of network security
the certification teaches you skills
from spotting and mitigating risks to
troubleshooting security incidents
it is to be noted that it professionals
with comptia security plus
know how to address security incidents
and not just identify them
so now that you know what comptia
security plus certification is about
let us look at a few points as to why a
professional must choose this
certification
the first reason being it's a vendor
neutral certification
the comptia security plus certification
is vendor neutral
which implies that you don't have to
center on technology and security of a
precise vendor
the skills and knowledge achieved
through this certification make security
professionals and network administrators
become in demand in the i t marketplace
the comptia security plus certification
is globally acknowledged to be one of
the fundamental security certifications
in the field of cyber security
comptia security plus certification is
universally recognized
and trusted across the world security
plus provides hands-on skills
one of the few entry-level cyber
security certifications that emphasizes
on hands-on practical skills
this ensures a security professional is
better prepared to solve
several complex issues of the current
times
the comptia security plus certification
is aligned with the latest techniques
and trends
it covers core technical skills in risk
assessment and management
incident response forensics and cloud
operations to name a few
thereby ensuring high performance on the
job
having this security certification
provides you a wider breadth of career
opportunities
the comptia security plus exam is
performance based
which makes the knowledge and skills
learned more applicable
there are numerous job roles that turn
to security plus to supplement baseline
cyber security skills
cyber security professionals are in
demand by organizations from both
private and public areas
with this certification you can take up
jobs related to compliance and
operational security threats and
vulnerabilities
access control and identity management
and cryptography to name a few
it is to be also noted that
professionals with the security plus
certification have greater opportunities
of receiving higher salaries than
non-certified professionals
another benefit of this certification is
that if you wish to get a cyber security
government job
obtaining the comptia security plus
certification will be an ideal starting
point for you
so now that you know the perks of
achieving this certification
what do you have to do to achieve this
well before you can achieve this
certification
you have to clear the comptia security
plus exam
let us now have an overview of the
comptia security plus exam
first and foremost who can take up this
exam
although comptia does not have any set
prerequisites organizations recommend
that candidates meet these two criterias
let's have a look at the two criterias
firstly
the comptia security plus is for it
professionals who carry a minimum of two
years of experience in the it
administration
focusing on security the comptia
security plus is ideal for professionals
who are looking to start or advance a
career in security
obtaining this certification prepares
the professionals for job roles like
system administrator
security administrator network
administrator junior penetration tester
security engineer and security
consultant to name a few
though comptia security plus is an entry
level certification
it is strongly recommended that you get
the a plus and network plus credentials
before proceeding to the security plus
certification
this will ensure that you have the
required technical skills like
configuring
managing and troubleshooting networks
now let's move on and understand the
comptia security plus exam details
comptia security plus sy-0601 is the
latest exam code that was launched on 12
november 2020.
the sy-0501 english language exam
retires on 31st july 2021.
hence we recommend you to opt for the
sy-0601 exam
there are a maximum of 90 questions
comptia security plus exam has multiple
choice questions
but some comptia certification exams
include performance-based questions or
pbqs performance-based questions test
the candidate's ability to solve
problems in a simulated environment the
passing score for this certification
exam is 750 on a scale of 100 to 900.
the duration of the exam is 90 minutes
so time management is crucial to clear
the exam since you need to solve each
question within a minute
comptia security plus sy-0601 exam is
currently available in english and
japanese language
you can enroll for the exam by booking a
slot online or registering with pearson
view testing centers
the price of the comptia security plus
certification exam is 370 us dollars
in australia the price is 500 australian
dollars and in european currency it is
334 euros
let us now look at the focus areas of
comptia security plus
exam firstly this exam focuses on the
core cyber security skills required of
any cyber security rule
such as security incident handling and
response intrusion detection
malware prevention etc the second area
of focus is threats attacks and
vulnerabilities
this includes analyzing indicators of
compromise and determining types of
malware or comparing and contrasting
types of attacks
next up we have identity and access
management
this topic emphasizes on implementing
identity and access management controls
or differentiating common account
management practices
the fourth domain that comptia security
plus focuses on
is risk management this domain describes
the importance of policies plans and
procedures related to organizational
security
finally we have cryptography and pki
here the exam deals with questions
related to comparing and contrasting
basic concepts of cryptography and
implementing public key infrastructure
another key focus area of this exam is
how to troubleshoot common security
issues
and deploy mobile devices securely
now coming to the final section of this
video where we look at the important
skills that you will acquire after
completing the comptia security plus
certification exam
first you will learn to detect various
types of compromise
and understand penetration testing and
vulnerability scanning concepts
this certification will give knowledge
to assess the security posture
of an enterprise network and recommend
and implement appropriate security
solutions
you will also get an idea of installing
configuring and deploying network
components while assessing and
troubleshooting issues to support
organization security
you will gain the desired skills to
monitor and secure hybrid environments
including cloud
mobile and iot comptia security plus
certification exams give the experience
to install and configure identity and
access services
you will understand how to identify
analyze and respond to security events
and incidents
finally you will grab another crucial
skill that is to implement best
practices on risk management
comptia security plus certification will
make you understand how to implement
and summarize risk management best
practices and the business impact
it ensures you operate with an awareness
of applicable laws and policies
including the principles of governance
risk and compliance
that was all about the comptia security
plus exam
taking up this exam will help you learn
a lot about cyber security and acquire
the necessary skills that will help you
become a greater cyber security
professional
this is why organizations look for
professionals with comptia certification
this certification is evidence of your
expertise in the security field
comptia security plus certification is
prevalent among security professionals
although the exam requires a lot of hard
work to crack the reward
is very fruitful all the best to
everyone who wishes to be comptia
security plus certified
that brings us to the end of this video
on comptia security plus certification
i hope this was informative and
interesting if you have any
questions regarding this video please
feel free to drop them in the comment
section below
we will be happy to help you thank you
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here